nice having to my team some of my team
with me so so proud of you guys
so good evening everybody what a journey
first of all I want to express my
deepest gratitude to the Academy and its
members it was an incredible week and
thanks for giving our film this
important platform facing makers based
on a true story and part of the costs
are long professionals with a refugee
background for example the small girls
playing in there they're from northern
Syria they arrived just two months
before we started to shoot in
Switzerland the translator
Alfred la vie from back tot his journey
took seven years to go to get to
Switzerland The Undertaker
Enver for Chile is from Albania and he's
playing himself because he used to be
the real Undertaker in the real case and
finally we have Jacob doe our main actor
protagonists with us here tonight
he used to be a big star in Syria before
he had to leave his country because of
the war to start from the scratch here
in LA and I'm so glad you're doing good
I'm so proud of you so why I mentioned
this is it was a very inspiring it was
very inspiring
as all of them shared their own stories
having a great impact on the film so
thank you so much for the the trust you
gave to me for this project and the
beautiful experience we had I could not
have done this film with Adam an amazing
cast and crew so thanks to every single
person who was part in this project I'd
like to introduce the ones who are with
me tonight stay came over all over from
Switzerland so stay there still
jet-lagged but you look really really
really good so first of all my producer
Shirley ents then is next is my first ad
martini oz we have Jay after we got the
my editor Simon good Knecht then we got
my line producer shield chairman then we
got my mother
[Applause]
and she did actually with my father the
catering so but I'm so happy you're here
tonight and I'm so proud you know you're
the most kind person I know and thanks
for reminding me I shouldn't sleep and
eat from white once in a while as a
mother so thanks to our family and close
friends for all being support always
supporting us special thanks to Peter
for a book house and my Swiss Cottage
regular and Nick Rosa another special
thanks to my close friends and GOP who
can't be here tonight
young meddler one laugh period or if
thank rowdy so love to everybody who was
involved finally there is one special
person I want to mention my dear dear
love our lashings who is the co-writer
or facing Mecca just being part of this
[Applause]
just being part of this incredible
journey since the very beginning and
without her this film wouldn't even
exist so thanks for riding this
rollercoaster with me thanks for being
so patient and patient and thanks for
your telling so I'm so proud of you and
I love you I love you guys I love you
good night
[Applause]